like there are people who literally
think this glass is empty there are
literally people who think it you know
and I just genuinely and I'm not kidding
like sorry I'm taking her water we're
gonna run out of room and I don't even
care about this carpet like like like
this [ __ ] right here
this is fullest [ __ ] for me fullest [ __ ]
drop you give me that I know exactly
what to do with it
I know exactly what to do with what's in
there and that's it that's my [ __ ]
life right there in a cup form that's it
I know exactly what the [ __ ] to do with
this and other people don't know what to
do with a full [ __ ] container yeah
what's up there's something very
powerful about consistency like I'm like
I eat my own dog food like I think the
thing that makes me sleep at night like
a baby is everything I tell you to do I
do like I don't even know how many
followers how many subscribers I have a
YouTube I subconsciously know and like
theoretically know that I'm not growing
on views on YouTube and weirdly I love
that because I think I'm doing this like
exchange program of people will watch
like four months of daily be and I'd be
like okay [ __ ] it let's go like you know
it's so crazy when you say the same
thing
eighty four thousand different ways you
never know when the person on the other
side is ready and you set it that right
way and that became it exactly what
happened I mean I had to hear it so many
times
realized what you were saying because a
lot of people said the same thing as you
said but it has to be someone I can
relate to and someone that I really
think okay she knows his shape like she
should know to me interesting the other
thing it's thank you the other thing
it's gonna be super interesting is when
the waste becomes real real I'm so deep
so heavy I have a funny feeling like a
lot of people hear me on social and are
going and it's working and in like 26
months when they plateau or they've had
success you know Plateau comes not like
you stopped growing Plateau sometimes is
you don't love it as much like you don't
feel on fire it'll be interesting I'm
you know I'm really fascinating to watch
what happens like the level of I've been
really thinking a lot lately for the
first time of like oh [ __ ] five years
from now is gonna be really cool level
of recalling content like I'm really
into like we're not doing a good job
with this but we're really doing the
team in a way that I think will like
there's so much throwbackthursday
like like content that I should be
putting out like it's just so
interesting to watch something from 2012
I love what I do that stuff but we're
not really going hard yet it's also
great to see like it's the same messages
over and over but then there's that Emma
would like the evolving over time and
the story is like
people say when I tell you when I'm
telling you about you it's a go it's the
same message and I'm like you haven't
got a really pay attention there's
nuances I mean in every every app be and
then and then the most important part is
I don't think what people realize is
especially if they want something for
themselves it's not about the content
it's about me executing the awareness of
the content its meta like once you get
it down there is the reason I think I
have longevity is cool you've got it
down your number same wavelength cool by
the way which is rare people like it so
you know anybody who says oh it's the
same stuff it's actually not in the zone
they're looking for an excuse like it's
the same stuff aka I'm not gonna let you
get away with it yeah which is why most
people don't want to actually stick with
me or like it they want the excuse a
hundred thousand percent or or what's
the saddest part is they want the
[ __ ] version of me which is they're
gonna I'm gonna pet make you pay me to
make you feel that way and because
you're paying me nine hundred dollars a
month you think you're doing something
well on the other side but I'm talking
about the person the person that's
consuming it the reason it's oh it's the
same thing is they want the excuses and
they want somebody say it's okay but
there's a scarier one to me that's okay
that's like you're that one's kind of
like you're compassionate but not
thoughtful contemporary right or it's
not okay let me rephrase it's one of two
people that's that gives you room to be
oh it's okay they love you blindly your
mom if you're lucky enough your sister
brother whatever somebody who loves you
and thinks they're doing the right thing
or somebody who loves you or doesn't
love you that just likes misery loves
company like the worst thing would be
for you to shine and not that they hate
you
it's just they hate themselves and if
you go and win it that sucks so that I
thought no it's okay because like stick
with me let's just let's watch the rodeo
tonight and do nothing right North
Dakota but but
the the scarier version of that to me is
the [ __ ] version of me when I watch
people comment like oh I get more value
from X I'm like [ __ ] they're in such a
bad place because they are paying
somebody to make them think they're
doing something that one's scary well I
like fun I something I'm trying to
figure out more of like fun is
interesting bartering is fun contests
are fun raffles are fun like it's a fun
way to get the community involved this
content is good like I think about all
the people that didn't win but now we're
gonna watch this video
who bought 10 who the this video cuz of
the Serendip it's better it's also meta
so much more matter than people realize
I bought 10 I bought 10 because I really
wanted to be one of you four people
right
I lost I'm a little mad I'm sad i
overextended myself what the [ __ ] am I
gonna do with like this is real people
like what am I gonna do with the ten
[ __ ] books now right but you know
listen when you're you know easier for
people in places of income where they
can afford it there's some people and I
always get scared of people over
stretching themselves for a lottery
here's the psyche it's the same people
that are paying those other people I'm
gonna win this is it it's my time I'm
convinced it's the [ __ ] secret out
here I'm gonna buy the temp books' I
can't afford the $180 that these ten
books but I'm gonna win I'm gonna fly to
New York Gary's gonna give me the
[ __ ] Midas touch and I'm and then
they the raffle happens that they losers
what's that's devastating to me what's
exciting to me though is they lose their
this video is gonna be put on YouTube
Facebook Linkedin they're gonna watch it
and something in your question makes
them willing to promote now and not be
like scared about it and the 17th time
they do it was the thing that led to the
same thing they were trying to do and
get by the Midas touch in this meeting
it's how it works for real interesting
right like people just not people you
know what it's the way I think about
branding and internet marketing internet
marketing aka last touch
tribution quant base math based selling
people are being thoughtful
they don't think Facebook works as good
as Google because of Facebook ad cost
them $88 to get a coach sold and Google
70 to what they don't realize as Google
does no branding and every picture and
video did branding for you on Facebook
bird to live that long
like it was he's 21 years old I it took
another 10 years before I even made my
first video online he's got 10 more
years of living right here 32 I was 31
years old I was 30 action was february
26 but it was it was you know what i
mean but but 32 i was two years in the
while every TV and nobody gave a [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] and to be very frank at the
level that were even talking about
nobody gave a [ __ ] few months ago
some people gave a [ __ ] you know now
it's everyone's gonna eventually give a
[ __ ] but yeah it's one that i really
live by well that's mine too yeah you
know that's we're so lucky about the mom
and dad's like my mom grew up in soviet
russia lost her mother at five years old
her dad went to jail for ten years when
she was 8 like she came to America with
nothing she raised three kids by herself
not one housekeeper for one day ever
when on one family vacation never bought
anything like and never complained so
I'm struggling I'm struggling I'm
struggling
I get empathetic I get am abetik I do I
don't get mad I'm telling you I get
empathetic I they don't have perspective
yeah yeah if your perspective I just
almost wish every day that people could
I would you know what I would love
virtual reality to do that there would
be an app I would build an app called
your family died that would be my app
you'd go into VR you'd walk in and feel
real and you'd watch your family go into
a car accident and you'd see their
[ __ ] death right and then you take it
out and then you live your life I
promise you you'll be happy as [ __ ]
about this video Yeah right he said he
was like that was an interesting moment
right we were very different on that he
was what was he he was like 15 he does
something in the morning I don't
remember that for missions year yeah
yeah and I'm like I just make more time
my mom's dead yeah he was like he was
like he was like but it's perspective I
do I do that because very natural real
war yeah like you guys know people who
died yeah I saw people dying on the
studio they were drove it over with yeah
like I saw that right like you can't
always see that no never I was four but
I still remember of course like I don't
have food I would have a [ __ ] that like
my parents are healthy my family's at
the end that Hylian nothing that keeps
me still going and being so humble even
though with 24 I make more money than my
dad doesn't tell you very fun person
it's just I genuinely think I'm going to
be like one of the most famous impactful
people ever and I feel like I'm gonna
feel the same way I feel right now which
is like hey okay like sir comes like
cool like what yes great I'm excited but
like I don't know I'm shot it's just so
obvious to me that people that have
perspective and don't you know and then
I'll die and for 42 hours on whatever
the way we communicate as humans I'll
get a ton of love you'll all tell your
stories and then everybody will move on
yeah and so like that's how I feel like
if that's what happened to Prince if
that's what happened to Maya Angelou if
that's what happens to like what's gonna
happen like what so that's it
I share the office if experiences
spoiled little brat and then yeah sort
of smoking weed I like fifteen or
sixteen and my dad just like said like
I'm not giving this [ __ ] I took away
everything except for the room pretty
much and just started like and was that
good it was a bad relationship
sure would be in hindsight are you happy
that happened because of course cuz I
have no news as a teen of course and I'm
gonna and then everything started
opening up it's like yeah honestly bro I
swear to God I really want this for you
yeah like it's kind of it was like
either I give you stuff or the weed and
I'm like well I prefer to be myself and
I and I went that path and it was that
was interesting how good just putting
pressure on the system whether well
however he contextualized it these are
all the things like you know what's
funny I just I said this once before I
used to say this I don't say much now
you know I just think you know there's
not a lot left here but like like there
are people who literally think this
glass is empty there are literally
people who think it you know and I just
genuinely I'm not kidding like sorry I'm
taking her water I don't even care about
this carpet like like like this [ __ ]
right here this is fullest [ __ ] for me
fullest [ __ ] drop you give me that I
know exactly what to do with it I know
exactly what to do with what's in there
and that's it that's my [ __ ] life
right there in a cup form that's it yeah
I know exactly what the [ __ ] to do with
this and other people don't know what to
do with a full [ __ ] container you
can't lose by pushing against your
parents if you follow your heart because
a if you're successful you're [ __ ]
Messiah and if you're not later later
later when they're really old they're
gonna look you dead in the face
hopefully nobody dies and everything you
get this moment they'll be proud of you
for going for it
your mom will secretly say hey by the
way remember 28 years ago when you went
for it and we were mad at you I'm proud
of you because I didn't go for it and my
mom once told me that she didn't go
forward to either your grandma you know
what I mean
progress that you can do to match
meaning it's real for so reckon and box
whatever so it's expensive and luxuries
and what I'm struggling with is that I
hear from a lot of people oh you should
go on Amazon and leverage that and eBay
and whatever but because it's such a
luxury product I'm afraid of putting
that on Amazon and either don't changing
don't the experience is one thing I was
worried that you were worried about
putting it there for brand perception
that those platforms would cheapen it oh
good
that's what I think you're actually
saying because the experience is your
[ __ ] shipping it DHL is DHL or UPS is
UPS or whatever is shipping it right
like I don't think that's what you're
actually talking about you're talking
about absolutely yes it it's not an
issue let me break it down for you so
it's not just blindly just listen to me
if somebody of high-net-worth look if
somebody's buying fox fur or raccoon or
whatever you know how much is it yeah I
mean eBay and Amazon are selling way
more luxurious and luxurious items it
will not cheap in your brand at all and
I do think it will give you more
exposure and more sales now you're gonna
make less margin than you selling it
direct but I do think of expands your
brand and I think that's a trade I do a
lot of like you know I for example I get
paid $150,000 to give a speech right
it's ridiculous it's amazing thank you
I'm so blessed but I'll give a speech
for free if I get an email right now
that says hey Gary or the high school
Association of America and we're doing
this first thing ever
we got a government grant and we are
bringing 1 million students to Central
Park 1 million I've forgot Central Park
see Portland some [ __ ] Park in
Portland look I don't want to make you
convenient for me in Portland a million
high school students and we want you to
give the keynote
I'll walk I'll walk because a million
people it's brand people get fancy when
they start making money yes I get 150
and I turn down 150 to speak all the
time yes I will do it for free
so when I talk about doing things for
free people get mad I've done stuff for
free my whole life because it's not free
the intent I say though this is back to
like how I desperately I'm trying to
figure out what you guys are talking
about which is like how do I help more
people actually understand how to get
the most value out of me getting the
most that's how I came up with don't
listen to what I'm saying watch what I'm
doing like that is why I think everybody
should watch me forever not they should
do what I do to you I don't watch your
content i watch how you can seem content
I know things about my audience not
based on what they're posting like I may
know more about like your habits like
some of these handles like pants 47 or
you know I may know more about their
habits or what they're reacting to even
and not even though they have two
children even though every post under
Instagram is two children so I watch
what people react to I think that's how
people should watch me I think people
should watch why I do things how I do
them and then do them if I start a
podcast you start a podcast if I start
doing more LinkedIn you start doing more
LinkedIn if I put a filter on my face
while I'm doing an Instagram live like I
just did you do that like there's like
like that is the game reverse engineer
me yes listen to me if you need the
motivation or an insight or you have a
business question fine and I'm flattered
and I love it but watch what why do I
use an example like rodeo when somebody
in the room just spent time in North
Dakota why do I say hockey in Canada and
football in the US and proper soccer and
luck
that's me communicating within context
got it watch what I'm doing is by
pushing gets your parents if you follow
your heart because a if you're
successful you're [ __ ] Messiah
and if you're not later later later when
they're really old they're gonna look
you dead in the face
hopefully nobody dies and everything you
get this moment they'll be proud of you
for going for it your mom will secretly
say hey by the way to remember 28 years
ago when you went for it and we were
out of you I'm proud of you because I
didn't go for it and my mom once told me
that she didn't go for it either your
grandma you know what I mean he asked is
the ultimate leverage in life you know
to me to me there are ton of people who
booed me along the way
who didn't want to see me succeed this
and that there's a great sir I wish
Brandon was here from Wine Library
there's a great story of a wine supplier
who [ __ ] on me so heavy and did such the
wrong thing such the wrong thing that
the wrong thing madman business yeah I
said this once before did something once
did something terrible to me did the
wrong thing by Wine Library under minded
me as a human being with straight lies I
went to an event in New York City where
I went to go taste his wine and he
[ __ ] said get the [ __ ] out of here
you're a piece of [ __ ] you're the worst
thing with the wine business and then
when Wine Library TV blew up he sent me
an email acted as if none of that had
ever happened and asked to be on the
show for exposure for his brand and I
said yes well because being the bigger
person is always right dude negative he
knew and I know as long as everyone
knows the score then like you don't need
to impose it holding that negativity
it's stopping you from what you actually
want to happen you know what I mean like
there's a level of being motivated and I
like that but fake motivator like to me
sports is fake like when I'm working
this is all like if I want to put GQ out
of business with my new 137 p.m. it's
kind of fake like I want to put GQ out
of business but I don't want anything
bad to happen to humans and like and I
say ok those GQ people will go work
somewhere else maybe I wonder if you
know so I think I think you need to be
thoughtful about friends and family in a
different way you have to create a
separate space for them because they
deserve it like you know no matter what
there is a counter-argument to like you
know when you were four they fed you
you know absolutely you know and I think
you need to reconcile I think the other
biggest piece of advice I'll give you as
somebody who's dealt with a lot of inner
family dynamics been in business with my
family like there's always stuff you
need to let poison out of your body if
there's thing you know your did
something and I caught it and I did it I
did it and I do it the way I reconcile
things that are frustrating me with the
people I love the most is by razzing and
being snarky and being and and drilling
them I do with my own team in a fun kind
of cool you know anybody's like my
parents or my children like there's you
know there's an undertone I get it I do
get it I really get it I think you need
to let it out it's been the best thing I
ever did my relationships with everybody
in my family and my team have been
exponentially better as I've in the last
half decade become a much better
communicator got it cool all right so
like wouldn't you okay I love what I do
right working with athletes in coaching
yes and I'm a runner myself and where do
you cross the line of like I'm not good
at you want to promote yourself but you
don't want to does that make sense of
just sort of from being able to self
promote but not they all look at me like
where do you find that line I guess it's
just a personal decision of where you
find that author do that that's exactly
right people have a different point of
view on promotion self promotion
bragging Charlatans you go you know
everybody's got look I mean the video
can look the video no but I mean it's a
really important point
like I no question sat for a good week
and was like oh really like I'm gonna
really let somebody follow me or like
what does that look like in real life
and this is three years ago now my
experience here's what I would say a
couple things a couple things I never
think the truth is bragging I just it's
very hard for me to understand how the
truth is bragging you know it's just the
truth right now let me let me tell you
another way you want to go different way
so I got a great idea for you and it
works for me at time sometimes I want to
say things in a different way
maybe what you do instead of bragging is
you hit up hundreds of running and
strength and health and wellness
podcasts little ones and asked them to
interview maybe the way that's right
maybe being interviewed is easier than
right that's what a lot of people do a
lot of people just get interviewed like
like I love when people like Gary your
suit yourself promote I'm like dick
you're on the [ __ ] interview circuit
like crazy you're doing the same thing
you're just disguising it yeah you know
yeah so I would think about that you're
welcome
we'll keep going around with something
guys for a while you know keep going
all right brother I don't have a crazy
question
sure something's gonna come up and one
thing I want to say is like thank you
like I had all my friends saying why are
you gonna ask where you're gonna ask
what do you want what you want and like
I don't really want like whatever I can
do to give back so I appreciate so what
do you think is going on I mean you're
so early in the journey like what do you
like what do you want to do do you want
to build a production company do you
want to make you know do you want to
make content and make a living of just
being a solo creator like how do you
think about it today
today like right now I think of it like
way I see myself like in long term right
Oh Laura had a lot of big company like I
love business more than anything like
growing up with my dad my dad's of
course no answering the phone and 12
years old just like that kind of thing
you know but you say you should forget
about everything till you're 29 like
yeah I'll do that resonating yeah you
like the process yeah I mean I look I
think you know at 21 I understood that
seems like you had that is what like
that is something I'm gonna have to go
deeper on like it it is actually the
ultimate I don't know like it's the
ultimate look and I see it in every
shape and size from crazy hedge fund gal
who makes 88 trillion a year and she's
loves that game it's about the money and
it's the point and Mazel Tov good for
her like she just loves the accumulation
of wealth as a hedge fund runner to
$39,000 a year you know you know works
in a corporation loves that stability of
nine-to-five loves three weeks vacation
loves half-day Fridays in the summer
loves being the coach of both son's
soccer and softball teams loves like
doing a very tedious job loves it loves
it's the [ __ ] there's nothing more
important than loving the process
there's just nothing else
everything the reason so many people are
making money online now is because
there's a way to love the process of
your process and make money because the
internet created that infrastructure in
the same way that blockchain will create
peer-to-peer transactions that keep the
transactions and money to people
that's what technologies do they change
everything like there used to not be
planes guys like I just know now it's
like understand how people don't
understand this like you weren't born in
America and like
like nobody knew anything about Asia in
this country until like 30 years ago
like it's you know like like there was
no sushi in [ __ ] in America 2530 years
ago
so anyway nonetheless that's great bro
like honestly like it's funny I'm going
through the same thing guys like the
sneak like I don't think people
understand why the sneaker thing is
happening or the stuff that I'm about to
do over the next 3-4 years I love
selling stuff it's fun like the idea of
buying something I love selling but I
love selling actual stuff more than I
like selling like I don't like selling
vaynermedia's services I do not get a
high I had a great meeting yesterday
we're probably gonna make we're probably
I probably sold something yesterday for
seven million dollars like in fee you
know staff it and we'll have five
against that I'll make two million
dollars profit not fun like like when we
do a one-off t-shirt on my Instagram
swipe up like one you know like I always
wonder if like people understand me like
that's the high like hey we sold $3,000
worth of t-shirt I'm like yeah you know
57 people have that t-shirt that's cool
no not 57 people one Instagram put me
know first why first there's a couple
things first it's so humbling that in
the same way that I want to wear a Macho
Man t-shirt belly you got like that's
it's cool to be like this human it's
just interesting it's cool that your
friends think this is cool like it's
good like like it's back to like not
getting too high like all the nice
things you guys set it for it's funny
that like somebody's two comments in a
row this happens all the time to me like
literally two comments in a row in an
Instagram or a youtube post Jesus Christ
Gary you're like Jesus right next post
this guy is so full of [ __ ] he's saying
nothing nothing ever right behind each
other they both grow through me the same
way
yeah like we can go to my last post I
guarantee they're both in there doesn't
doesn't
I just don't hear it I just don't hear
it I don't hear it I don't hear it cuz
I'm in my process so back to my question
no I think my crescendo like my most
calm
cuz I'm an operator too like when I hear
a big company where I get scared is I'm
like I hope that kid understands the
skill set it takes to be an operator not
a creator not a seller an operator is
very different which I was blessed with
as well and there's no question the
underestimated part of my career I don't
think you'll understand what I actually
do like you know I don't think people
understand the magnitude of like
building from scratch zero a billion
dollar revenue business around services
not an app right services
this is [ __ ] intense you don't miss
this business there's 150 million with
800 people you know businesses do 700
million with 43 this is not a good
business this is hard but that's okay I
know why I'm doing it
and I'm doing it because when I buy a
wine brand or a sneaker but when I buy
case Wes and 52% of the people here are
now our case Wes and k-swiss actually
becomes Nike or adidas like that's why
I'm doing it
I think it's strategy I think personal
development done right is actually
strategy it's like having like being
optimistic is actually just it's
actually why I'm poking a little bit
like I want to get something like to me
when somebody's winning you quantifying
anything that's a negative is so
important because you want to put them
in the right shelves yeah like what are
the right ones you know it's like I
still like I know you know there's a big
difference of like remembering
everything you know versus contextual
like for my father it's hard he like he
he he doesn't get over things and it I
watch it
and I could sense it you know you have
to because you have so much more upside
then so you know I think the I think my
thing is I run hot and cold
I run high and low I pull from opposite
directions what I like about you is I
think you understand mentality but then
you also do when I hear personal
development and motivation I get scared
because I see a world when whenever I do
a keynote with Tony Robbins I'm doing
some events I genuinely believe that
audience skews towards not doing I
genuinely do I think they go to that
conference to get motivated
check-the-box a version of paying
somebody to be in their mastermind I'm
doing something no you're not and I
genuinely think that that's why I'm a
lightning bolt in a lot of ways as a
personal and like it comes from like
because people are very different and
like passionate reactions to me because
I'm doing something fundamentally
different I really am
I believe in that mentality strategy you
know but [ __ ] man you better work if you
want you don't have to work you have to
know yourself but like nobody's building
building a million dollar business on
some trick or a shortcut it's crazy how
much just comes
it's always about execution it's my same
thesis on names when people like what
should the name of my thing be I'm
always like it won't matter if you can
execute I'm faking it till you make it I
like back in university I picked up
illustrator I was never doing the
homework I was just doing skills on the
side like learning Adobe yes Serena and
basically York went on strike the school
I was going to for three months and I
decided I wasn't going back I dropped
out and I I got obviously have been
using Adobe Illustrator for six weeks
and I went to a job interview everything
they said I was just like yeah I can do
that I can do that no problem to me
brother that's a little bit different
than somebody going on here's what I'll
tell you what fake it to make it is a
kid rents a tuxedo rents goes to his
uncle's best friend's house rents a
Lamborghini drives it to that house pays
some Instagram models to come it and be
in a bikinis and then say this is my
life and you can do this too if you pay
me $6,000 to teach you how and there's a
lot of that or like borrowing like I've
literally had people say Gary B you can
help me I read a lot of [ __ ] Gary Vee
you can really help me I need your help
and the next line says if you lend me
$10,000 I'll give it right back to you
and so once it'll all play a little bit
and be like for what like and like I
know you hate it but I'd love to take a
picture with it that's weird you said
that I actually randomly for the first
time in five years or eight years had a
random thought of like whoa what would
it be like Oh actually it was two nights
ago my friend Lou my friend Lou was like
I went to Vegas and did this thing and
it was just something about the way he
said I'm like and nobody knew who he was
it's funny that it was the first it's so
funny you ask that first of all nobody's
ever asked me that question and I've
never thought about it this is what I
believe in like everything's in the air
obviously in some weird way it's not
that I miss it everything has a price
everything has a price and if you aspire
if crazy and ambitious and wonderful
thoughts of like Maya Angelou and Gandhi
run through your head you're gonna have
to realize cool that also means that
there's going to be not many times ever
again that I will not be not known and
that is weird because I almost can't
remember it at this point and it's only
been it's only been 18 months where I
now know if I'm out I will be recognized
only 18 months even though I've been
around for a decade only 18 months where
I know for a fact it's impossible for me
to go somewhere and not have somebody
Know Who I am now that's because mainly
I'm in New York like it's also where
it's not like if I thought what the
north yeah I mean no no I know there's
people there but but in reality
everybody it's easier yeah no I know
it's it's like even in North Dakota and
Cosmo and bran randon people like I mean
I was in the gym this morning at six
o'clock and I like that you shower and
getting ready to come here legit and
like a big guy is just like oh he's like
getting shaving or something like stupid
right and he's like oh no I want to get
in your way and I'm like oh has to go
and I just decide to ask him how he's
doing and you know
locker room right and and and I'm like
oh yeah I'm eating this one dude you
know in New York it's like I'm super
excited Gary it's like no you know no no
no you said I'm meeting a random dude
too random dude in a gym and his first
thing was you're mean Gary okay I said
yeah this guy's an ad agency and he's
like oh you're meeting Gary okay well
that's not bad that was yeah you know
it's it's it's happened so yeah I mean
the answer is no but I'm aware of that
it's never gonna be like it was and I
lived a you know unlike you know I think
it's a new mats not unusual what's the
right way to put it 30 40 is not the
most common you start having you know
fame comes for athletes and actors and
you like entrepreneurs now becoming
famous is also 20s and you're really
passionate about something if you really
want to do something you should
absolutely do it for free as long as you
can humanly do it and in your 20s you're
more likely to be okay with living with
folks be okay with getting together with
six buddies and living in a [ __ ] if
not even eating caviar like you know
like next month next month of rent and
that's why I always that's why I razz
it's why i razz products a lot even
though I sell sneakers it's not I don't
expect it like I don't want people to
buy watches or Supremes or even my
sneakers if they can't afford it you
know not if it's not if it's coming at
the expense of them investing in
themselves go ahead we'll keep going
around and around around good when you
get where you want to go and you have
hard choices to make the thing the
things that motivate me
before kind of doing motivate me now of
course this December something something
you struggled with and do you have any
advice well I don't think it's a
struggle I think it's an accomplishment
if you're in a place where you're
motivated myself you know me people live
88 years of their lives motivated by
money and never get away from it because
they never achieved the money right
interesting you know many people are
motivated by the chase of Fame for 92
years of their life and never stopped
because they never got famous like like
this is such a fun this is what this is
about that is such a subtle terminology
shift you've been looking at it as a
negative
it's a massive it's a it's a massive
absolutely yeah like it's like oh let me
let I apologize but I want to frame it
for you like I'm secretly worried that
I'm gonna get to a place where I'm not
gonna care anything about business and
it's the love of my life
Evan if I was gonna be some run you know
it gets weird like you know of course
you don't get motivated by the same
things that's a great accomplishment
brother especially at this young age ya
know like I said in my 20s I define
myself by the grind and I was totally
okay with that for the rest of my life I
remember talking to like my friends are
like where are you going with this like
like how you ever gonna make a ton of
money for like graphic designing or they
start up so now I'm just like I just
love it I love like learning new things
discovering it's also there's also have
done that for 50 years there's also
there's also did you also have the
feeling of like there's also an amazing
part when you feel like you know
something and a lot of other people
don't know it and then like and you
genuinely believe like there's an
incredible feeling of accomplishment
when you know the unveil I mean I got
ragged on so heavily for starting a
YouTube show like made fun of for
starting a website like like got so much
snarky comments of starting an agency
writing a book speaking starting a
sneaker like everything I do I get made
fun of even now it's different level of
people that are making fun of you it's a
different you know it's somebody you
know it's but it's a it's the
best it's my preference I like the bees
much more than the cheers that's the
space and I know how to navigate that
actually leads me into my next question
if I may say okay oh yeah
so like I've achieved success very
quickly and it's sort of started to like
I better have some interpersonal
challenges makes sense and it's sort of
like interesting like and I don't really
know how to reconcile this so like maybe
we like people in my life like people
who are distant and close now industry
me differently differently I can give a
bunch of examples about probably get me
some just something just you know bigger
hugs my family's throwing me a surprise
birthday party um like when I get back
from the Irish like I wants and it's
well I found out admission have it but
like why are you doing that you I would
have never gotten a surprise birth I
think success was an attached to that so
the Soviet Verizon money so I think that
some the first part felt really easy and
awesome this one I think you have to be
thoughtful about let me explain your
there's so I think people are a little
confused actually this is a finally I'm
like excited I think I can articulate
this well ready I like the boos more
than the cheers when I'm playing the
game when I'm on the ice when I'm on the
court got it
that is a motivator the second I'm off
the court it goes the other way I think
what you need to think about is
reconciling what drives you
professionally and not deploying that
same thing personally yes I'm watching
you rose I can see it for me I you're
deploying cynicism against those
behaviors for no reason there's no
upside like to me if your parents were
bullying you on the court that's a
different thing than off the court right
right
got it but but that also leads into you
like just your ideas like how do you
like before when when you're not
successful you put out idea
and whether whether they're good or bad
even if they're good ones you have a 54%
chance of someone like thinking that
it's goat or even thinking that you can
execute that idea you know I think now
that when you have success people
everybody think is everything I say
smarts you find that here's here's the
good news here's the good news the good
news is even though I get motivated by
the booze versus the Cheers that's one
that's the micro in the macro I can't
hear anything like you know I'll to
explain you know I just don't value
anybody's opinion and more importantly I
don't but I don't judge them then either
if I don't value your opinion friend
well then when you say it's stupid and I
win I don't judge you for it
because it wasn't a factor at all so I'm
not gonna impose on you either there's a
level of I think there's a sense of
responsibility with success that I'd
like to put pressure on which is being
the bigger person like to me to me it
just plays out very simply the chess
pieces which is like what's in it for
you to impose a negativity even though
you know they're pandering to you in a
certain way there is no you you've won
you know to me it you know to me when I
win there is no interest in spitting it
on you after I beat you right
yeah I mean like I just don't see you
know like you want